Why else would she
have that dildo
they found
in her green room?
Yes!
Hmm?
You tell me that!
That supposedly hot
and (bleep) girl, huh?
The one she bought
that was the size of
a midget's fist!
Why do you need
one of those
if guys want
to (bleep) you, hmm?
Hmm?
Hmm?!
Let's talk
about that!
All right,
let's talk about it.
Let's get it in here
and take a look at it.
You want to see the dildo?
He wants to see the dildo,
he's gonna see the dildo.
(man 2)
We all know
what it looks like,
but what are we gonna get
from seeing it again?
I'm sick of it.
I've seen it ten times!
I'm sick of it!
(man 3)
The gentleman has a right
to see the exhibits
in evidence.
(man 4)
A dildo is
pretty good evidence
no one will
pork her.
My God, it looks
like a femur.
(man 4)
I mean, why even
make those things?
Women don't need
orgasms.
That's science.
Lots of people
have them.
I have one.
Hey, what's
the big idea!
Whoa!
What are you
playing at?
Oh, bother.
It's my wife's.
She doesn't use it
because she's alone.
Quite the opposite,
actually.
We use it,
and we love it.
He must be hung
like a hamster.
I am perfectly
average.
And I have
a donkey dick.
Hey, let's take
another vote.
If anybody thinks
that Amy Schumer
shouldn't be
on the TV
'cause she's not
hot enough
for whatever reason...
raise your hands.
And those who think
that she is hot enough?
You're on board
with the toad now?
I wanted to (bleep) Natalie,
from "Facts of Life."
I did.
I wanted to (bleep) her,
and I wanted to fall asleep
with my head on her stomach.
And Amy is hotter
than Natalie, so...
I'm sorry...
but I'd (bleep) both of 'em!
And I want to (bleep)
Blake Shelton.
Has the world
gone mad?
This girl thinks she deserves
to be on camera?
She's not a "10"!
Maybe you're not
a "10" either.
(bleep) you, man!
(all) Hey, hey, hey!
(bleep) you!
Do you really
mean that?
want to (bleep) me?
Or are you just
being a tease?
So, you just carry that
around wherever you go?
In case a dildo-based
argument breaks out?